all right everyone we've gotten to one
of my all-time favorite multivariable
calculus topics divergence and in the
next few videos i'm going to describe
what it is mathematically and how you
compute it and all of that but here i
just want to give a very visual
understanding of what it is that it's
trying to represent
so i've got it here pictured in front of
us a vector field and i've said before
that a pretty neat way to understand
vector fields is to think of them as
representing a fluid flow and what i
mean by that is you can think of every
single point in space as a particle
maybe like an air particle or a water
particle
something to that effect and since what
a vector field does is it associates
each point in space with some kind of
vector and remember i mean whenever we
represent vector fields we only show a
small subset of all of those vectors but
in principle you should be thinking of
every one of those infinitely many
points in space being associated with
one of these vectors and the fact that
they're kind of smoothly changing as you
traverse across space means that showing
this very small you know finite sub
sample of those infinitely many vectors
still gives a pretty good feel for
what's going on
so if we have these fluid particles and
you you know have a vector assigned to
each one kind of a natural thought you
might have is to say
what would happen if you let things
progress over time where at any given
instant
the velocity of one of these particles
is given by that vector connected to it
and as it moves you know it'll be
touching a different vector so its
velocity might turn it might go in a
different direction and for each one
it'll kind of traverse some path as
determined by the vectors that it's
touching as it goes
and when you think of all of them doing
this at once it'll feel like a certain a
certain fluid flow and for this for this
you don't actually have to imagine i
went ahead and put together an animation
for you so we'll put some water
molecules or dots to represent a small
sample of the water molecules throughout
space here and then i'm just going to
let it play where each one moves along
the vector that it's closest to
and i'll just let it play forward here
where each one is flowing along the
vector that's touching the point where
it is in that moment
so for example if we were to you know go
back and maybe focus our attention on
just one vector like this guy one
particle excuse me
he's attached to this vector so he'll be
moving in that direction but just for an
instant because after he moves a little
he'll be attached to a different vector
so if you kind of let it play and follow
that
particular dot
after a little bit
you'll find him you know elsewhere i
think i think this is the one right and
now he's going to be moving along this
vector or whatever one is really
attached to him
and thinking about all of the particles
all at once doing this gives a good sort
of global view of the vector field and
if you're studying math you might start
to ask some natural questions about the
nature of that fluid flow
like for example you might wonder if you
were to just look in a certain region
and count the number of water molecules
that are inside that region does that
count of yours change as you play this
this animation as you let this flow over
time and in this particular example you
can look and it doesn't look like the
count changes certainly not by much it's
not increasing over time or decreasing
over time and in a little bit if i gave
you the function that determines this
vector field you will be able to tell me
why it's the case that the number of
molecules in that region doesn't tend to
change
but if you were to look at another
example like um
a guy that looks like this and if i were
to say i want you to focus on what
happens around the origin in that little
region around the origin and you can
probably predict how
once i start playing it once i put some
water molecules in there and let them
flow along the vectors that they flow
along
the density inside that region around
the origin decreases so we put a whole
bunch of vectors there and i'll just
play it for a quick instant just kind of
let it jump for an instant
and one thing that characterizes this
field around the origin is that decrease
in density and what you might say if you
wanted to be suggestive of the operation
that i'm leading to here is that the
water molecules tend to diverge away
from the origin so the kind of
divergence of the vector field near that
origin is positive and you'll see what i
mean mathematically by that in in the
next couple of videos
but if we were to flip all of these
vectors right and we were to flip them
around
now if i were to ask about the density
in that same region around the origin
you can probably see how it's going to
increase and when i play that fluid flow
over just a short spurt of time
the density in that region increases so
these don't diverge away they converge
towards the towards the origin
and that fact actually has some
mathematical significance for the
function representing this vector field
around that point and even if the vector
field doesn't represent fluid flow if it
represents like a magnetic field or a
um
an electric field or things like that
there's a certain meaning to this idea
of diverging away from a point or
converging to a point and another
another way that people sometimes think
about this if you look at that same kind
of outward flowing vector field
is rather than thinking of a decrease in
density imagining that the fluid would
have to constantly be repopulated around
that point so you're really thinking of
the origin as a source of fluid and if i
had animated this better a whole bunch
of other points should be sources of
fluid so that the density doesn't
decrease everywhere but the idea is that
uh points of positive divergence where
where things are diverging away
would have to have a source of that
fluid in order to kind of keep things
sustaining
and conversely if you were to look at
that kind of inward flow or what you
might call negative divergence example
and you were to play it but it were to
go continuously you'd have to think of
that center point as a sink where all
the fluid kind of just sort of flows
away and then that's actually a
technical term people will say the
vector field has a sink at such and such
point or the you know electromagnetic
field has a sink at such and such point
and that often has a certain
significance
and if we go back to that original
example
here where there is no change in fluid
density right
what you might notice this feels a lot
more like actual water than the other
ones because there is no change in
density there and if you can find a way
to mathematically describe that
lack of a change in density
that's a pretty good way to model water
flow and again even if it's not water
flow but it's something like the
electromagnetic field there's often a
significance to this no changing in
density idea
so with that i think i've jabbered on
enough about the visuals of it and in
the next video i'll tell you
what divergence is mathematically how
you compute it
go through a couple examples things like
that see you next video